JOANNA SMITH: This
is your Recents menu,
also called the Overview screen.
Some apps have more than one
card in this Overview screen,
which can make
them seem special.
So how do those apps swing it?
Well, the Overview
screen is not actually
a list of the recent
apps a user has used,
despite what you may think.
Rather, it is a list of tasks.
Side note-- if you'd like
to learn all about tasks,
check the link in the
description below.
Ian has a lot to say.
Tasks are a great
way for your app
to distinguish between
disparate elements
where a user might want to
switch between each piece.
Consider an email app
with a task for the inbox
and a separate task for
composing a new email, so
that the user can reference
back to the existing email
when drafting their response.
This is a beautiful
use of tasks.
Another useful way to think of
how your app should use tasks
is to consider the
multi-window implications.
In the multi-window world, each
task will have its own window.
So if two elements of
your app should logically
exist independently,
but side by side,
that's a moment for tasks.
We call multiple tasks
"concurrent documents."
This sense of your
app multitasking
is where the "concurrent"
part comes in.
You've got a stack of activities
that the user probably
wants to interact
with in parallel
with another stack
of activities.
The "document" part is
actually shorthand for anything
that you create that
lives separately
from the rest of your app.
So it could actually be a
document in a text editor,
but it could also be that draft
email, or a separate browser
window, or a
specific conversation
view for a messaging app.
So the first step in
creating concurrent documents
is identifying what should
logically exist independently.
And to that end,
multi-window really
helps distinguish good cases
for concurrent documents.
Any time you'd want to see
two activities side by side,
those would have to
be separate tasks.
To add a task to
the Overview screen,
there is a pretty
helpful manifest
attribute you can
specify when registering
an activity in your manifest.
"android:documentLaunchMode"
has four possible values.
"intoExisting" re-uses any
existing alternative document
for this task, but
creates a new task
if one doesn't already exist.
"always" will create a brand
new document for the task.
"none" creates the
task in the same window
as the current activity, a.k.a.
On the same stack.
This is the default behavior.
And "never" serves to
override any specified flags
and permanently keep the
task in the current stack.
What specified flags
am I talking about?
Well, if you prefer to determine
whether the task should
be in a separate
document dynamically,
you can specify flags
when starting the Intent.
To be clear, the creation of
a task isn't actually special.
You'll create an Intent and
pass it to "startActivity."
But the creation of that Intent
is where you can get clever.
If you haven't already, it's
time to meet the "addFlags()"
method.
"FLAG_ACTIVITY_NEW_DOCUMENT"
is fairly straightforward.
It tells the system to
treat this next task
as its own window in
the Overview screen.
If there is an existing task
with the same base component
name and data URI, the
system will use it.
This means that your
new document could be
replacing an existing document.
However, you can override
this default behavior.
If you always want the system
to create a brand new task,
you can add the
"FLAG_ACTIVITY_MULTIPLE_TASK."
In multi-window mode,
this gets even better,
as you can use
"FLAG_ACTIVITY_LAUNCH_ADJACENT"
in conjunction with
"FLAG_ACTIVITY_NEW_DOCUMENT"
to hint to the system that
the task should be launched
alongside the existing task.
So the manifest attribute
and the intent flags
offer you the same options.
"intoExisting" is
equivalent to using
"FLAG_ACTIVITY_NEW_DOCUMENT,"
whereas, "always"
is equivalent to using
"NEW_DOCUMENT" and
"MULTIPLE_TASKS" together.
Keep in mind, though,
that an attribute only
needs to be specified
once for the Activity,
while a flag will need to
be added to every Intent.
So you'll probably
want to choose
a path based on the variability
of your Activity's use case.
But between manifest attributes
for default document behavior
and flags for dynamic
task creation,
your app will be dominating
that Recent screen.
Just, you know, be
sure that domination
is thoughtful and
useful to a user,
because you don't
want to go crazy
and get yourself uninstalled.
So now you're ready for
concurrent documents.
Check out the blog post linked
in the description for more
usage information and for code
that you can copy and paste
into your own app to
build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]